ever since I could remember I'd like
making stuff I'll just make things you
know my backgrounds really pottery is
really ceramics touching the clay
touching the mud making things with with
clay so the clay is mixed with about 50%
sawdust dry clay dry sawdust but more
and more as I started to do that
I also had this little I don't know what
it was this urge ability interest for
teaching for education making stuff and
teaching stuff but actually you can do
that that's called the ping an art
educator or a teacher the idea was that
the making and the teaching and the
learning and the asking of questions
through art through the visual imagery
that you're talking about that was what
was so important to search for the good
and make it matter this is the real
challenge of the artist the kind of
group that has self-assembled today
speaks to multiple interests that have
Henry felt like singing but slaves
didn't dare sing in the streets instead
he hummed all the way home and trying to
weave it into what is an art education
how does one learn through the making of
things through cultural production yes
filters been filtering water what kind
of questions can we ask not just about
what someone else has made but what kind
of questions can we ask through the act
of making itself I'm thrilled that
you're all here you're thinking about
these ideas I hope you take back even a
small bit of what we've talked about
what you've heard from others into your
own teaching experiences and perhaps in
some way our conversation can continue
you